[Music]
on this Tuesday night shakeups on
Parliament Hill and Capitol Hill
Canada's new speaker makes history in
the House of Commons please treat me
like that new car and don't give it a
dent on the first day so does his
American counterpart but for all the
wrong reasons the office of speaker of
the house is hereby declared vacant
going nowhere fast why Rush our ground
to a hole for thousands of community in
Toronto decision Day in Manitoba the key
writings and how the leaders have
performed during the campaign and where
are the Bloody Marys the crunchy
obstacles scattered across this Canadian
Highway global national with Donna
freezen good evening and thanks for
joining us after that embarrassing
moment when members of Canadian
Parliament applauded a man who fought
with the Nazis MPS have elected a new
Speaker of the House of
Commons
the Greg Fergus was chosen by secret
ballot he is the first black Canadian to
take on the role elected as a liberal MP
his job now requires him to be impartial
ensure parliamentary rules are followed
and perhaps the biggest challenge
maintain deorum McKenzie gray
reports a century old tradition for a
historic
moment liberal MP Greg Fergus now the
38th Speaker of the House of Commons
tasked with policing an unruly Bunch
respect is a fundamental part of what we
do here we need to make sure that we
treat each other with respect but that
respect is rarely seen in a chamber
prone to unparliamentary language and
debate but Fergus believes he can change
that as the commons referee if members
are willing to work with him nobody pays
good money to go see the
referee they go to see the stars you but
those star players couldn't help
themselves turning congratulatory
remarks to Fergus into stump speeches we
must continue to work together to make
life more affordable to build more homes
to keep our democracy strong government
that is excessively powerful and costly
that has overburdened the population the
NDP leader avoiding those partisan
punches congratulating Fergus on
becoming the first black speaker there's
going to be kids who maybe have come
here and not seeing themselves reflected
on the walls and that's going to change
now a sentiment echoed by liberal
colleagues the fact that we now have the
first black speaker in the history of
our country is something to behold
fergus's colleagues voted him to the
speaker's Chair by secret ballot beating
out six other MPS who all shared his
desire for a more polite Parliament the
speaker has a responsibility and
privilege to lead by example at all
times outside of becoming the new
defender of decorum Fergus gets a nearly
$100,000 pay raise bringing his salary
to over A4 million dollar a year and he
gets to move into the speaker residence
the farm in the beautiful gatau Hills
Donna okay McKenzie gray in Ottawa thank
you in the US the Speaker of the House
of Representatives has been ousted from
his job and it's all because of fighting
within the Republican Party conservative
members of that party led by a
hard-right congressman from Florida
claim the Republican speaker could not
be trusted and late today the house
voted to remove Kevin McCarthy leaving
the chamber without a leader Joel senk
is watching the drama in Washington Joel
how did this all play
out this took a couple of hours this
afternoon Kevin McCarthy grasping to
that position as Speaker of the House of
Representatives threatened by a small
faction of far-right members of his own
party who were successful in taking that
gavel away from him
216 people voted members voted against
him eight of them Republicans from his
own party removing McCarthy from the
position hereby declared vacant a
historic defeat descending the US
Congress into a political tail spin on
Tuesday Kevin McCarthy became the first
ever Speaker of the House of
Representatives removed from his post by
his colleag
chaos is Speaker McCarthy chaos is
somebody who we cannot trust with their
word the motion to remove the former
speaker was brought forward by Florida
Republican Matt Gates a Hardline
conservative and McCarthy adversary who
accuses the speaker of working with
Democrats to pass last minute
legislation last weekend to keep the
government open they wanted to challenge
me because I worked with the other side
so America could go forward and
government could stay open
you know if you have to lose for
something I will always lose for the
country are you tell McCarthy could only
have four Republicans vote against him
if every Democrat did as well in the end
eight members of his GOP caucus chose
not to support him we need a speaker
ideally somebody who doesn't want to be
speaker and hasn't pursued that at all
cost for his entire adult life the White
House says they hope the house quickly
elects a new speaker and is chastising
Republicans for causing chaos in
Congress it is not helpful to the
American people to have to see that
going on McCarthy's reign as Speaker
ends as bumpy as it began it took 15
rounds of voting over multiple days and
a number of concessions to become
elected back in January one of those
compromises allowed a single member to
bring forward the motion to remove him
from office he wanted the speakership so
bad that he gave away the tool to have
it taken away
so the big question is what happens next
the Republican caucus met tonight to
discuss just that where McCarthy said he
will not run again for Speaker of the
House meaning someone else will have to
come forward right now political experts
say there is no front runner on the
Republican side to do that Donna more
political drama to come Joel senic in
Washington thank you it is election day
in Manitoba and the outcome is expected
to make history one of these leaders
will be the next Premier either
incumbent Heather Stephenson a
progressive conservative or NDP leader
wob Cano or the Liberals doal Lamont
though he is considered to be a long
shot with me from Winnipeg ahead of our
live election night coverage is Marne
blunt Marne polls close in a few hours
what kind of a campaign has this been
well Donna this has really set up to be
quite an exciting night here and an
exciting election the progressive
conservatives looking to hold on to
power at the Manitoba legislature while
the NDP they're looking to turn the
province orange once again and the
Manitoba liberals meanwhile are hoping
to take away some of that vote and
prevent either party from getting a
majority now the polls are favoring NDP
leader wob Cano and if he wins he'll
make history is not only the first first
nation's Premier in Manatoba but also of
all the Canadian provinces his entire
campaign focused on Healthcare including
promising to reopen three Winnipeg
emergency rooms reversing a previous PC
government decision I feel like it's a
it's a high honor that we get the
opportunity to put our names on the
ballot and to ask you the people of
Manitoba to vote for our vision of
fixing Healthcare uh we've done the
campaigning and now it's up to you the
people of Manitoba Progressive
conservative leader Heather Stephenson
has fallen behind in the polls a win for
her would also be historic though making
her the first woman Premier voted in by
Mana Tobin she's standing by the
decision that her government would not
support the search of a landfill north
of Winnipeg where it's belief the
remains of two indigenous women are
located her campaign has also centered
around affordability manitobans the
decision is up to you an NDP who
disregards the law raises taxes puts
Manitoba in debt and has no experience
or an experienced PC team who will make
your life more affordable make streets
safer meanwhile liberal leader Dugal
Lamont has positioned his party as the
alternative between between the PCS and
the NDP but pollsters say it's likely
much of the liberal vote has fallen to
the NDP Lamont is even at risk of losing
his seat in St bonfice you can make sure
that there's a minority government and
you are free to make it happen by voting
Manitoba liberal you do not have to hold
your nose and vote NDP to get rid of
Heather Stenson and the PCS you can stop
them both by voting Manitoba liberal and
this election has also already saw
record-breaking advance polls with more
than 200,000 manitobans already casting
their ballot ahead of election day Donna
okay could be an indication of Interest
tonight Marney blunt in Winnipeg thank
you our chief political correspondent
David Aken is in Winnipeg too hi there
David you know the progressive
conservatives are hoping to win a third
term this is Heather Stephenson's first
time running as leader though what
struck you about her
campaign well listen Donna the PCS had
to do this they had to overcome the
perception that the progressive
conservative government 7 years in power
was tired lacking energy had had no new
ideas did Stephenson do that I don't
think you can make the case that she did
let's look at the last week of messaging
from that campaign we see these landfill
Billboards very odd issue to stake the
survival of your government on I think
you lose as many votes as you get h a
negative campaign that the PC's launched
in the last week attacking the character
of new Democrats and let's look at the
leader herself Heather Stephenson she
was in Winnipeg yesterday for the first
time in 10 days 10 days at the end of
The Campaign and she's not here where in
Winnipeg where all the campaigning all
the ridings are that matter so Heather
Stenson really didn't seem to have her
heart in it on her by contrast wob Cano
in the NDP very disciplined very focused
campaign Donna so David where will this
election be won and lost well as with
any Manitoba election it's Winnipeg and
I've got the results from the 2019
election on the board right now the end
of the night the score was 36 for the
PCS NDP had 18 now the NDP need to steal
some PC seats and it turns out the seats
they're all aiming at I've got my hand
over them they're all seats held by
ministers so ministers have to fall in
what I'm calling the blue wall of
cabinet ministers uh the the health
Minister for example Audrey Gordon is in
one of these um these three writings
here probably the most conservative part
of Winnipeg all ministers including the
premier's writing of tuxedo right there
but two more ministers in the Northeast
may be vulnerable so if the NDP does
that and they're aiming at it then we
get to 28 for the PCS 26 for the NDP 29
is the magic number for a majority now
as Marne said the NDP have been saying
to liberals please if you want change
you have to vote NDP liberals come vote
NDP it's sort of a mirror from what
happens with the federal system and that
means Dugal Lamont's writing right here
bonfice wob Cano the NDP Leader's been
in that writing three times put that one
in the orange column there's a riding up
here in the north called MC Phillips a
lot of liberal votes there if those
liberals come over to the IND P put that
one into the orange column and then look
where we're at 28 for the NDP 27 for the
PCS that's the math that sets wob Cano
up to be the first First Nations person
to be the premier of a Canadian province
Donna okay David Aken in Winnipeg thanks
David there was commuter chaos in
Toronto tonight go trains and VIA trains
in and out of Union Station as well as
cn's customer portal all stopped working
Cen rail called it a systemwide failure
Kayla mlan is at Union Station in
downtown Toronto Kayla tell us what
happened Donna things have died down a
bit but as you can imagine major
headaches for commuters in the thick of
rush hour here at Union Station now
according to go transit a CN Network
wide system failure is to blame for the
outage affecting all rail corridors that
means go transit up Express VIA Rail
they were all experiencing delays but
some limited service is now up and
running here at Union trains are now
running about every half hour apologized
in a statement explaining that it's
currently dealing with an internet
connectivity issue and that along with
metr links and VIA trains out of Union
Station its customer service portal has
also been impacted as a result Cen EXO
and Amtrak trains however are still up
and running they say while there is no
indication of a cyber security issue at
this point they're still investigating
the cause of the outage I I just going
to have to wait and see like they really
isn't an alternative I need to take a
train so Ubers are out of the question
really at this point they've jacked at
their prices we've already taken a look
no we have to get back to home and do
many other stuff and it's unfortunate
right so wait and see what is happening
I'm fine doesn't matter when I get home
like I'll get there I had to go home and
I have to pick up my son from his class
I'm struck
here if I delay more than 10 minutes
they are going to build
me now at this point no time has been
given as to when trains will be fully up
and running Metro Links advising
passengers to seek alter
alternative Roots if they can uh now
Uber roots are also Uber rats are also
through the roof um we spoke with one
viewer who told us that from Toronto to
Hamilton the going rate right now is
$442 Donna yikes Kayla mlan in Toronto
thank
you there has been a terrible bus crash
near Venice Italy at least 21 people
have died 18 others are injured it's
reported the bus broke through a barrier
plunged off an overpass fell onto power
lines and caught fire local Reports say
the bus was carrying foreign tourists
back to a campsite the mayor calls the
scene apocalyptic emergency crews are
still there and there is no word on the
cause the sour relationship between
Canada and India coming up what the
Indian government demands Canadian
diplomats do by next
week the dipl atic Rift between Canada
and India is growing deeper India has
ordered two-thirds of Canada's diplomats
in that country to leave by early next
week things turned from tense to sour
after prime minister Justin truda went
public with allegations Agents from the
Indian government were involved in the
killing of a BC sick leader on Canadian
soil Eric Sorenson looks at where this
troubled relationship stands right
now 2third of the Diplomatic core at
Canada's High commission offices and
elsewhere in India have been ordered out
it's an escalation the Prime Minister
was hoping to avoid we're not looking to
escalate as I've said we are going to be
doing the work that matters in uh
continuing to have constructive
relations with India through this
extremely difficult time a reduction in
Canada's diplomatic staff in India could
increasingly affect travel trade and
business between the two countries a lot
of different Services provided by its
diplomatic staff some would be Consular
there would be trade and Commercial
officials of course there would also be
Intelligence Officers India's prime
minister has dismissed allegations that
his government was behind the murder in
BC last June of siik leader hardip sing
nider an advocate for an independent
kistan Us and other allies showed
support for Canada's investigation but
have not been openly critical of India a
vital partner in counterbalancing
China's Growing Power Canada is learning
a hard lesson about today's geopolitical
relationships says this former Diplomat
the world's power shifting to a new
geography
where it's much harder to navigate these
relationships and you know you don't
have the luxury in today's world of of
picking perfect friends on Tuesday India
raided the home of prominent journalists
cracking down on what it calls foreign
propaganda it's not connected to
Canada's diplomatic row but it is a sign
to some of the Modi government's
Hardball tactics towards those who
publicly criticize India but it's part
of a broader Trend we see in India over
the last few years has been a
suppression of civil Liberties um
particularly of activists and
journalists and writers who are seen as
critical of the government for now
Ottawa has few answers on what it should
do next Beyond quiet diplomacy we've
been in close contact continuing to
engage on the question of our diplomatic
for both sides somehow have to show
restraint uh and and let some time pass
let it deescalate and says Arif Lani
Ottawa clearly has work to do to find a
way forward with India on the murder
investigation Eric senson Global
News the US is cracking down on
potentially hazardous space junk it has
issued its first fine to a company that
failed to move an old satellite to a
safer place the US says it posed a risk
to other satellites orbiting Earth Dish
Network has admitted liability and
agreed to pay
$150,000 and holy Clamato juice a celery
spill closed part of Highway 400 in
Ontario this morning an entire truckload
of it police arrived to take stock of
the situation and decided to divert
traffic until the cheese whz truck
arrived I just made that last bit up
they actually cleaned up the celery and
everything is
fine financial fraud trial ahead the
founder of a fallen crypto company in
court jury selection has begun in the
criminal trial of Fallen cryptocurrency
King Sam bankman freed he's accused of
orchestrating one of the biggest
Financial frauds in American history
prosecutors say he stole $ 8.9 billion
do from his FTX customers to prop up his
hedge fund by real estate and make
political donations he was once seen as
a leader in the crypto industry but his
company declared bankruptcy last year he
has pleaded not guilty to seven counts
of Fraud and conspiracy opening
arguments begin tomorrow
and a groundbreaking trial began today
for a former RCMP director Cameron Oris
who was accused of breaching National
Security ortis appeared in a Ottawa
courtroom today pleading not guilty to
leaking top secret information he was
the head of the rcmp's National
Intelligence coordination Center at the
time of his arrest in 2019 he faces six
charges including four counts of
violating the security of Information
Act it's the first time a court has
tested charges under the security of
Information Act or is faces up to 14
years in
prison next why in Ontario first nation
is keeping tabs on Manitoba's
election people in Ontario can't vote in
a Manitoba election but many members of
an Ontario First Nation are watching
their neighboring province with interest
one of their community members Manitoba
NDP leader wob Cano could be the first
first premier of any Province Melissa
Rin takes us to en igaming it's more
than 300 km east of Winnipeg on the
shores of Lake of the Woods
Ontario this is a long way from the buzz
of the motoba campaign Trail but the
ajibu of igaming are heavily invested in
the battle next door where Progressive
conservatives and the NDP both hope to
form the next government there's a guy
from your community who could be the the
first premier the first First Nations
Premier in a province MH that would be
amazing I didn't think I'd see that in
my lifetime how do you do I'm W Cano NDP
leader wab Cano went to school here
learning a jibway he grew up here for a
while in in our community here inaming
with the family and they still come here
um you still see them here every year um
he comes to our annual Pao he uh come
brings his family and and they dance and
it's always good to see him uh come back
his parents moved the family to Winnipeg
when canoe was young he's got no
shortage of supporters back home
including the cooks he's going to be the
next Premier for sure I I believe it I I
myself think it would be a real awesome
thing if he won because our community
has been in a state of emergency for a
long time it would uh it would give our
community members a lot of hope that
anything is POS possible the community
of 800 has on average a funeral every 3
weeks many from overdose and suicide
someone doing well is valued I've been
CH for about two years now and I've been
telling everybody that I'm introducing
awaba as the next future premier of
Manitoba most can only cheer from afar
but some can show their support at The
Ballot
Box I think we've got probably somewhere
between 50 60 oning members that
actually live in Manitoba and we'll have
the opportunity to vote regardless of
what manitobans decide canoe is a star
here onam is very proud of him Melissa
Ren on igaming First Nation
Ontario and that is global national for
this Tuesday I'm Donna FZ and tonight's
your candidate is the CN Tower in
Toronto it will be lit up in Blue
tonight as the Toronto Blue Jays kick
off this year's MLB playoffs in
Minneapolis against the Minnesota Twins
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow
bye-bye
[Music]